in the bustle of leicester's market it
can be hard to stay two meters apart
and even though it's outside many
shoppers choose to wear masks
well i try to keep safe myself and try
keep other people safe as well the new
vegan supposed to be more infectious
and it's supposed to be more virulent in
sticking to your lungs
i'm a lot more cautious but i like
shopping in the market because i
get my produce and back home pretty
quickly
and it is outdoors it's outdoors and
that's the reason i come down
it's the spread of the virus through
casual contact with infected people that
is ultimately putting the vulnerable in
hospital
so with a new variant of the virus
that's more transmissible
are the old rules that beat the virus in
the first wave
enough so you get a lot less exposure
if you're in back extra one meter away
this doctor says no
even outside staying three meters away
from other people would be safer
the exposure intensity is less outside
but it's not zero
so if you think of somebody who's
actually smoking in a queue like in a
bus q for example
you can smell that smoke even several
meters away if you're downstream of that
person
same with the supermarket cue with
people breathing out the virus although
you can't smell the virus
every exhaled breath from an infected
person can contain around
200 virus particles and even though
there's only one documented case of
transmission outside
it doesn't mean it doesn't happen back
in the first wave
walking down the street was like doing
the slalom we went to such lengths to
stay away from each other
now it's all so different people lean
across you in the supermarket they
invade your personal space
in the queue perhaps we've lost our fear
of the virus
but this behavioral psychologist says
the threat from the new variant has
rekindled the fear and the national
lockdown has brought back the sense of
community
the vast majority of people are sticking
to the rules
potentially some of the behaviors we got
away with a few months ago we might not
be able to get away with
with the new strain of the virus but it
also does seem to suggest
that we do need to go further and
certainly this lockdown at the moment is
not as strict
as the lockdown that we had last spring
even though the virus itself
is more contagious the risks of virus
transmission inside
are almost 20 times higher than they are
outdoors
several supermarkets have said they'll
ban shoppers who don't wear masks
unless they have a medical exemption the
risks outside
aren't zero though how close the contact
needs to be
and for how long is uncertain but there
is
pressure on the government to take the
precaution of toughening up the rules
thomas more sky news in leicester